who do you think that Peter ends up with
nobody knows everyone keeps asking me
this and I honestly have no idea who is
barb crying about I don't know I wish I
knew because it's literally driving me
insane all of us insane oh I have no
idea I have absolutely no idea what goes
down all of us are gonna be just as
surprised as everyone else's to how
things play out but I'm excited and if
Peters got really some really tough
decisions to make and so um Madison and
Hannah Ann are here in the end
Madison is revealing some things to
Peter she hadn't before how do you feel
watching all this and how do you think
it's gonna end
oh my gosh I'm like on my toes because I
want to know what happens
who is barb crying always barb crying
about someone bring her something get
her home - barb it's so hard to watch
Tammy I mean watching it when you're in
the house you you feed on people's
energies and you feed on their
relationships with Peter has other
people even though if you don't want to
so very early in I knew that Madison and
Peter just have this fire they have this
connection that I didn't have with him
but it was it was very clear so um
looking now I feel like whoever he does
end up with I know that he's very much
in love with that person who is barb
crying about Sidney who is barb crying
about you know what I don't know it's a
question for the ages every time I see
that clip I'm like barb just tell us
you're like I'm just like waiting for
them to pant it like give us some info
give us a I don't know I truly have no
idea we're all watching it seems so now
we could find watching every Monday and
like just give me a little bit more
please I gotta know what about Peter
coming down to Madison and Hannah Ann in
the end who do you think he will pick
and who do you think he should pick
they're both great girls they're both
great girls um I got to know them a la
there's different things about them
though so like I don't know his
relationship with either one of them on
that kind of level but you can see that
he truly does care for both of them and
I think that's why it's so hard and he's
so upset in the previews because it's
like I don't even think he knows who
he's gonna pick
but the beginning of the tell-all Chris
Harrison said this is an ending where no
one knows how it will end
not even Peter do you not know how's
your season it's it's definitely a
chance about that yeah
helped me understand that things just
are you know they continue to unfold
until the very last second and I don't
know when that last second occurred so
does that mean that right now you might
be unclear on someone's feelings for you
on if you're in a relationship that's
what it sounds like man you love to push
this yeah I am you guys will see
[Music]